évidemment ça marche moins bien que dans
les films vous l'avez compris
aujourd'hui je vous parle de fantômes
existent-ils vraiment que dilation sur
ces étranges phénomènes pour prendre
courage à deux mains direction l'atelier
qui n'est pas en thé
bizarre j'ai l'impression d'être suivi
croyez-vous au fantômes si c'est le cas
vous n'êtes pas là ou le seul selon un
sondage datant de 2019
32% des Français affirment croire aux
fantômes ou aux esprits et ce n'est pas
un phénomène nouveau les histoires de
fantômes et d'esprit circulent depuis
l'Antiquité tenez Homer punaise mais non
pas celui-ci Homère l'auteur grec qui
entre parenthèses a hanter tous les
cours de latin il fait référence dans
l'Iliade on est bien d'accord Homer
n'est pas un fantôme quand je dis qu'il
hante les cours de latin c'est une façon
de parler là tu brilles les pistes
revenons à nos fantômes ils peuvent
prendre plusieurs formes d'abord il y a
le traditionnel d'un seul blanc avec
deux trous à la place des yeux c'est le
plus simple cette représentation est
liée à une ancienne tradition funéraire
datant du Moyen-Âge
parfois la dépouille du défunt était
enveloppée dans un seul blanc le blanc
symbolisait le calme et la sérénité
avant le passage vers l'autre monde
quand l'âme c'est levée elle emportait
tout à fait logiquement le linceul d'où
cette représentation parfois le fantôme
se présente sous la forme d'une
silhouette flottante plus ou moins
vaporeuse parfois le revenant se
matérialise sous la forme d'une voile
lointaine
quelques fois c'est un simple courant
d'air
une porte qui claque un objet qui tombe
on fiche la trouille doucement ça c'est
ce que l'on lit dans les romans et les
contes fantastiques ce que l'on voit
dans les films personne n'a encore plus
prouver scientifiquement que les
fantômes ou les esprits existaient
vraiment et bien d'autres théories ont
été avancées pour expliquer ce genre de
phénomène ah tu me rassures tiens
suis-moi je vais te donner quelques
exemples
ce décor une table avec parfois un verre
au centre je suis sûr que ça vous parle
il s'agit de l'équipement de base pour
communiquer avec l'au-delà autrement dit
l'esprit des personnes qui ne sont plus
de ce monde c'est ce qu'on appelle le
spiritisme et bien au départ il s'agit
d'une blague une supercherie montée de
toutes pièces par les surfox nous sommes
en 1848 aux États-Unis Maggie et Kate
âgé de 14 et 11 ans font croire à leur
mère et à une voisine qu'elles peuvent
communiquer avec un esprit qui leur
répond en frappant plusieurs coups sur
une table
les adultes demandent ta voix enfin à
entendre et de fait l'esprit frappe
en fait c'est juste une blague
d'adolescente mais avec le
bouche-à-oreille le phénomène soi-disant
surnaturel se répand comme une traînée
de poudre six ans plus tard le
spiritisme compte plus de 3 millions
d'adeptes les deux sœurs deviennent
finalement célèbres à travers tout le
pays communicant avec les esprits lors
de séances rassemblant des centaines de
personnes jusqu'à ce que 40 ans plus
tard Maggie révèle à la presse la
supercherie en fait elle utilisait une
pomme attachée à une ficelle pour
provoquer les coûts ainsi que les
craquements de ces articulations malgré
cette révélation les adeptes refusent de
les croire et rejettent le surfox qui
finiront leur vie dans le dénuement
les spectres vont également profiter du
progrès technique de l'invention de la
photographie notamment le photographe
William mumler prétendait capturer
l'image des revenants grâce à cette
invention attestant ainsi de l'existence
des fantômes c'est en tout cas ce qu'il
a fait croire à de nombreuses personnes
à Marie thug Lincoln en particulier
l'aveugle d'Abraham Lincoln le 16e
président des États-Unis il l'a prise en
photo dans les années 1870 regardez sur
le cliché en arrière-plan on devine les
contours d'un personnage qui ressemble à
son mari sauf qu'Abraham Lincoln est
mort assassiné quelques années plus tôt
en 1865 en fait même l'heure était un
petit malin il a utilisé un trucage
souvent mis en oeuvre par la suite au
cinéma une technique qui consiste à
superposer deux images en l'occurrence
ici celle du président Lincoln et une
autre de sa femme la photographie de
passer au début tout le monde n'y a vu
que du feu jusqu'à ce que même l'heure
finisse par être démasqué et j'ai trouvé
une application qui permet de faire
apparaître des fantômes
il est pas mal notre Jamila la
technologie peut-on engendrer des
phénomènes qui en toute bonne foi
peuvent faire croire à la présence
d'esprit heureusement il existe une
science qui est là pour démêler le vrai
du faux et elle porte un joli nom la
zététique zététique et toc les fantômes
la zététique c'est en fait l'art du
doute ou l'art de faire preuve d'esprit
critique
c'est un art bien utile en ce moment
pour débusquer les fake news sur
internet par exemple et qui s'applique
aussi à l'examen de photos sur
lesquelles certains prétendent qu'un
esprit s'est incrusté allez un exemple
concret vous êtes prêt
la méthode diététique permet de
comprendre que le point lumineux qui
apparaît à côté de moi n'est pas un
fantôme ou un spectre mais qu'il est dû
à un phénomène de Halo qu'on appelle un
facteur de flair c'est en fait une
aberration optique qui est liée à
l'orientation d'une source lumineuse par
rapport à la caméra qui me filme en gros
la diététique c'est esprit critique et
tu l'as oui et parfois c'est notre
cerveau qui ne joue des tours
regardez cette photo il s'agit de la
planète Mars certains y voir un visage
cette photo de la surface de Mars a été
prise le 25 juillet 1976 par la sonde de
Viking 1 et quand on dit mars bien
évidemment on pense aux petits hommes
verts du coup le cerveau se met à
travailler tout seul il interprète fait
des liens entre ce qu'il observe et ce
qu'il connaît du coup le visage saute
aux yeux pourtant il s'agit simplement
d'une formation rocheuse une sorte de
but comme on en des dizaines sur Mars
mais sa forme et la lumière rasante
au-dessus donne vraiment l'impression de
voir un visage humain d'ailleurs depuis
la NASA a pris plusieurs autres clichés
du même site à plusieurs autres moments
qui prouvent qu'il ne s'agit pas d'un
visage ce phénomène s'appelle la Parisie
de lit de la même manière en fonction
des circonstances on va reconnaître une
silhouette dans une forme floue un
visage dans un nuage de fumée et les
exemples sont innombrables
impressionnants
les paris de lit peuvent également être
auditives on entend un son et on va
chercher à le rapprocher de ce que l'on
connaît le phénomène se produit souvent
quand on écoute une chanson dans une
langue étrangère on a parfois
l'impression d'y entendre des phrases en
français tiens petite démonstration avec
cette chanson du groupe scorpion still
loving you
[Musique]
vous pensez avoir entendu certaines
paroles et bien pas du tout voilà ce que
dit réellement le chanteur
[Musique]
allez un autre exemple
aucun mot de français dans cette
histoire il s'agit de l'hymne national
russe preuve que notre cerveau cherche à
reconnaître des sons familiers même si
ça n'a aucun sens si vous aussi vous
avez des exemples comme celui-ci
n'hésitez pas à me les envoyer en
commentaire
parfois on ne voit rien et on entend
rien et pourtant on ressent quelque
chose il ne faut pas sous-estimer la
force de la suggestion si je vous assure
que mon atelier est hanté parce que
quelqu'un y a été assassiné je vous
rassure c'est pas le cas et bien vous
risquez d'interpréter plus facilement le
moindre son au mouvement comme une
manifestation paranormale et oui on se
fait vite des films d'ailleurs des
chercheurs en ont fait l'expérience dans
un théâtre ils ont indiqué à une moitié
des visiteurs que le théâtre était hanté
et à l'autre moitié qu'il était en
rénovation et bien ça n'a pas loupé les
premiers ont décrit plus de perception
étranges que les secondes hallucinant
ces histoires c'est la magie de notre
imagination
et les tables et les Verts qui bougent
ça aussi ça s'explique oui et selon la
science cela s'appelle l'effet
idéomoteur ce sont en fait des
mouvements involontaires que nous
faisons de manière complètement
inconsciente lors des séances de
spiritisme par exemple des participants
qui s'attendent à ce que les esprits en
communication avec eux pourront faire
bouger le verre d'eau sur la planche de
widget pour le diriger vers des lettres
et tout ça sans s'en rendre compte et
sans faire exprès les faits idéomoteurs
est tellement puissant que les
scientifiques estiment qu'il est capable
déplacer des tables à l'insulte des gens
à l'origine du mouvement finalement
toutes ces explications peuvent se
combiner et suffir à créer de toutes
pièces des fantômes c'est l'expérience
qui a fait un groupe de Canadiens dans
les années 1970 ils ont imaginé un
aristocrate anglais qui serait mort 350
ans plus tôt et ce serait appelé
Philippe il lui aurait inventé toute une
vie puis une mort enfin les participants
se sont rassemblés une fois par semaine
pour une séance de spiritisme afin de
tenter d'entrer en contact avec le
fantôme de Philippe et bien au bout d'un
an ça a fini par marcher en posant des
questions à Philippe ils obtenaient des
bruits en réponse et voyez la table
bouger comme si croire au fantômes
pouvaient suffire à les faire apparaître
la science et l'esprit critique ont
ainsi pu donner une explication à de
nombreux mystères mais d'autres restent
sûrement à élucider chacun est donc
libre de penser que la science y
parviendra un jour ou que c'est la
preuve que les fantômes et les esprits
existent
toutes ces histoires finissent par me
faire froide dans le dos allez à bientôt
les épicurieuses et les épicurieux et
n'ayez pas peur si vous avez aimé cette
vidéo abonnez-vous et laissez un pouce
bleu
c'est en tout cas ce qu'il a fait croire
à de nombreuses diverses la science et
l'esprit critique ont un problème
[Applaudissements]